[Music]
look at what i woke up to how cute is
this
ma bear's making waffles with little
taika close it monkey
is it hot
how long do you have to wait for no clue
no clue
for ten minutes
ten minutes that's four minutes
wait what if it gets burnt
you don't know mama no i have no clue so
you just go by the feel of it or does
the light turn
this thing's a little cheeky seven
dollars the guy got from school what is
that um
toy spider toys colors wow that's cool
so we'll see what it turns out
oh it smells like something's happening
did you forget to put sugar earlier yeah
are you serious that's not even part of
the traditional recipe really there's no
sugar in there
you mean
why are you making it sound like it's a
secret wait so it's not going to be
sweet the other waffle
probably not it's just how how the chef
intended it yeah i intended it
i wasn't hungry but now i am is that
normal smoke no it smells good
let's see what it looks like
whoa
golden brown
that was golden brown
how much timer hey google
how much time is left on the timer
t minus 66 seconds ooh i think it only
might be like a two minute thing
what do you think is it this is small it
looks golden brown it looks perfect
but i don't know if the inside is good
whoa
is it hot is it crispy
whoa it's really good you made this dude
good job
it's
goose it's hot dude
okay you ready for another one
we're gonna make another one yeah let's
do the whole thing this thing is like
perfect is it i want to taste it
no no it's too hot
for you not for me
let me see
let's see
that's a good one
is it hot it's fluffy it's really good
i still have him
oh man that was really good good job
mama oh thanks good job tycoons
but i'll take all the credits
that
is a very smart idea monkey
he's like i know look at that
he's putting a chocolate chip in every
one of the squares and one in the mouth
no more in the mouth
he says one on the waffle one in the
mouth
are you kidding me what about here you
missed one
i get every single one you got to
maximize it
there you go oh yeah
you're smart look at that
that looks delicious
you want to use a fork to cut it up and
eat it
you use your hands
like a man huh
yeah you're gonna break it dude all
right that's it
[Applause]
okay what do you got
wow it melted
that's amazing
[Music]
is it good it's yummy huh can you help
me with mine i want some chocolate chips
on mine too
okay thank you so much i thought you'd
never ask dad
you're a special chef
are you making one too
that's cute
the special taika chef touches
oh you do a good job attention to detail
look at that
wow
i think they were pushing it in like a
puppy
you don't have to push it in i want to
is it one thumbs up or two thumbs up
two thumbs
up do it okay my turn
copy cat yep
all right
let's see how the chef made it
no really good
look at that
melted chocolate
delicious is it really good honestly
really good
i'm excited
all right cool now they're putting on
the second layer
they have the scissor lift here
and then they got the boards put up they
got the glue
in place they got the suction cup on the
marble
it's crazy that they have to get that
big old machine
through that door
you're crazy
all right check it out the update almost
complete
just one more layer
but man it looks pretty good look at
that
high contrast
and now which is pretty interesting
i have my first
business meeting
in las vegas i know a lot of people come
to vegas
to do business meetings because that's
where a lot of the conventions are
whether it's for wholesale for cutting
some manufacturing
um what is that um computer one like ces
sema which is the automobile one all
that and what's cool is i get to go to
this business meeting as myself still so
rocking the barbell statement t
bam
got my camo pants on
got some cool shoes on
got a cool watch on
and we're gonna meet up
plan out some dope stuff for barbara
brigade for next year 2022 and yes we
are preparing for next year
and then uh grab some food and they
booked a steakhouse which means i have
to wear pants you guys know i try not to
wear pants unless it's cold
and the weather's really good right now
but i have to wear pants so
that's what i'm rocking
[Music]
all right so
the installers
are gone for the day
look at this
wow
this
is
stunning
talk about making a [ __ ] statement
they just need to finish that part but
yeah
and then that middle piece right there
it's gonna be cut off it looks like a
sad face right now huh it's gonna be cut
so it's just gonna be our fireplace just
that straight line but i don't know why
maybe for reinforcement or something
they kept it and i guess later on
they're cutting it
but isn't this gorgeous you guys
never in a million years did i think i
would be putting stone
inside of my [ __ ] house
like what
this is rad man i'm
so stoked
to be able to do this [ __ ] like
come on
and it's beautiful because this is
natural the stone is natural initially
we were going to just try to be more
cost effective we didn't really give a
[ __ ] about name brand stuff we don't
really we gave a [ __ ] about quality
things but we were like if it's gonna
look just as good and it's gonna be
cheaper of course give me that
alternative
but then when we looked at the actual
slabs
like this because it's natural it's one
of a kind
so no one's really gonna have that
not to say that i that myself or bart we
care about any one-of-a-kind stuff we
don't really care about that
um like i said we really care about
quality stuff so if everyone had this
[ __ ] we don't give a [ __ ] it's this is
our place and you know we're the only
ones seeing this we don't care
that
million other people have the exact same
thing we don't really care
um but when we saw the slab
of the alternative that would be more
cost effective it's made from porcelain
and because it's manufactured
they can make the pieces look perfect so
and it's going to be cheaper right like
i said cost-effective
so i'm like yeah i don't care let's do
it
but then when we saw the actual slabs it
wasn't that nice and they said if you
scuff it the first layer of it is the
print
after that there's no more print
and again we were like well it's not
going to be a big deal like how many
things are gonna scuff this wall like
what are we doing here right
we still didn't care but then when we
saw the price difference we're only
gonna be saving a few hundred bucks
so i'm like
no let's just get the real thing and i'm
really glad we opted for it because it's
just so beautiful
it's one of a kind and then when you get
close to it
it has so many cool
imperfections
and it just has like that glitter
let me see
like this can you see from this angle no
i think the sun setting so it's not
really going to capture it very much
let me see if i move an angle
no you don't really get to see the
glitter sparkly glitter in it
but
yeah
i'm glad we went with this
this is stunning i think it's known
i think it's called as panda it's like a
panda print
because it's primarily white and black
so
yeah look how they matched it and
everything
do you like it
nope no because it doesn't come with me
no do you like this the fireplace
ugly okay thank you thank you for the
honest opinion
well someone here is not a fan
can't please everybody
debbie what kind of what kind of candy
is that baby okay it's a baby candy but
really that candy is bomb i used to eat
that candy in high school all the time
and it's sour it's caramel sour apples
so the outside is caramel the inside is
a sour apple lollipop oh if you haven't
had it try it
all right so
taika and i
were enjoying our dinner we ordered some
cheese pizza of course
because that's what kevin
um from i was gonna say full house what
am i talking about
um home alone
eats
and we're about to watch some tv because
clearly
under construction so we're gonna watch
some tv over here
baby
yep
hey
funny guy
this is weird
[Music]
careful i don't want you to get a
splinter on your foot okay because it's
still wood
okay okay you're gonna get a splinter oh
my god don't give me something nervous
okay let's go upstairs
oh my god dude careful okay that would
give you a splinter and it's going to
hurt what yes that maybe we should wear
shoes inside the house
that's fine
oh god okay yeah you're making me
nervous
oh you okay
i know i've been just telling you
welcome to being a parent man
you literally tell them
the answers to the life quiz
and they don't listen and i know all the
parents watching right now going
oh [ __ ]
that are like older than me going no
[ __ ] you stupid ass yeah we're dumb i
get it what baby
i'm giving you leche yep
i should just start a channel and leave
the camera on you 24 7. you're so
entertaining dude
no one's allowed in here at all taika is
ready for bed
look at this little cutie it belongs to
my teacher and on that note
good night
good night